welcome back to another edition of the
gadget lab i'm michael colori i'm
christina bonnington uh coming up in a
little bit we're going to have robbie
baldwin he's going to show us a new
tablet for reading books but first
christine is here to show us this giant
ipad on a stand yeah this isn't an ipad
this is the
new 21 and a half inch imac
it's been out for a couple weeks now and
we've been using it and
it's it's pretty great it's also very
thin
it's alarmingly fitted yeah so these
edges are five millimeters thin at the
edges and it kind of uh it's concave in
the middle but it's still pretty slim
i've been yeah i've been using it for
the past few weeks and it's been pretty
great this version has a 2.9 gigahertz
core i5 processor
and it's got apple's fusion drive which
is a mix of flash and hard disk and it
optimizes where things go at the system
level
start up more quickly yeah so it's super
fast um doesn't hang up on anything
uh that's one of the foundations that
like ultrabooks and super portable
computers sort of brought into the into
the scheme of things right yeah and so
it's in the it's in the imac that's a
250 upgrade i'm not sure if everyone
would kind of need something like that
uh i think more if what you do is you
know very cpu intensive if you're you
know really need to optimize performance
on your machine i think it'd be worth
the upgrade but i think for most of us
you don't need to you know spend the
extra cash on that
the quad core processor is
good in itself
saves you enough time on boot up to go
for yourself another cup of coffee yeah
so it does not have a physical disk
drive it does not so uh yeah there's no
room yeah
so if you want a disk drive apple has
this 80 usb superdrive you can get which
coordinates you know that matching
aluminum you just plug it into one of
the four usb 3.0 ports and it just sits
next to it and you know that works fine
you know it doesn't have a little paper
clip thing yeah where you can put the
paper clip in and the disk will pop out
and get stuck in there and the
eject command won't respond yeah that's
a little concerning yeah it's it gives
me pause
because uh that little paper clip has
saved my life maybe 100 times yeah and
during my life yeah i guess you'll just
have to invest in like a hammer and uh
if it gets stuck in there yeah that's
not a good idea well actually yeah
speaking of a hammer this thing is not
upgradable is it no there's no way to
upgrade the internals on this on the 27
inch version there is a little trap door
in the back you can tap and you can
expand the memory but this version does
not have that okay um that is going to
bother some people
it will bother some people you know it's
also yeah you know it also means it's
there's how are you going to repair this
thing the
uh the display is uh the cover glass is
laminated to the led portion so you know
if you crack that you've got to replace
the entire display portion um and then
there's you know no way to get inside
the back
uh so i mean i understand why the people
are making you know a big deal out of
the fact that a lot of the newer
computers are non-upgradable but at the
same time
i kind of think it's where it's going so
we should get used to it yeah
um
it's kind of tough to square though for
a device that's supposed to last you
three or four years
you know you're really limiting
expandability you're sort of also
limiting its lifespan yeah
yeah so you've got to think you know
when you buy it you know how much memory
are you gonna need uh you know how much
storage space i think comes standard
with one terabyte but you can upgrade to
three
um
yeah and then you know apple does do a
pretty good job of using environmentally
friendly materials and making it
recyclable they have a whole website
page dedicated to explaining you know
their processes and stuff great washing
yeah and i mean they get a lot of flack
for it you know because their products
aren't very easy to to repair or
anything but they're trying yeah well
you know whenever people are buying a
new computer being like the technology
friend or whatever you probably get this
too people ask me what should i do what
should i do i always tell them buy as
much memory and as much storage space as
you can afford
because it's way better to have too much
than it is to have too little right
right and it'll help you down the line
yeah so
you know i guess that advice is now more
uh
is better than ever now yeah
so take that advice i guess um yeah so
starts at 1300 and then uh this version
uh with the 2.9 gigahertz processor
starts at 1 500. okay and goes up and up
and up and up from there yes
and now when is the 27-inch version
coming out so it also started shipping
if you if you're one of the first people
to pre-order it you might already have
it on your desk but for most of us uh
probably sometime in the new year
shipping's kind of delayed slow and how
long until it gets retina dude i want
that retina
probably you know a year or two i mean i
can't imagine how hard it is to make a
retina display for something this large
but the display is fine it's uh you know
it's high def it looks great and you're
not like using your desktop computer
with your eyes three inches from the
screen so well yeah
you know what take this thing away and
bring it back to me when it has a red
knob
just kidding uh well thank you
and uh we're gonna bring out robbie now
show us the new device from kobo
all right now roberto is here and he has
brought with him
the new kobo ark it is their uh new
seven inch tablet obviously it's going
to be going up against the nexus 7
but more importantly the kindle fire and
the barnes and noble uh nook hd
um it's it's a pretty nice i i just got
this like like literally last night so i
haven't had a chance to really mess with
but their uh their ui uses something
called tapestries so their folders are
kind of dynamic they're all moving
around
otherwise it's it's just stock android
though yeah it's just 4.0 it's ics yeah
it's skins ice cream sandwich skin
skinned but
you can you can side load apps on this
so if you're looking for
a tablet that is part of a ecosystem a
book ecosystem but you want an open
tablet you might want to look into uh
this little kobo arc it does feel
heavier than let's say the nexus 7. so
it's it's you know but you know work it
out gotta look good yeah summer's coming
uh yeah yeah they have a little tapestry
and then they have this little just a
discover ribbon they call down here and
yeah
what do you think compared to compared
to stock android with nothing on it uh
compared to stuff i mean it looks cool
the tapestry ui but
actually looking at it closely
everything seems a little fuzzy and it's
not the problem of the display because
if you launch like a an app when you go
in the app it looks nice but for some
reason the ui seems a little fuzzy
like i said i just got this we're going
to see if maybe they'll have i'm going
to talk to them see if maybe there's an
update coming or not and i'll have a
review of this thing it's gonna it
starts at 200 bucks pretty much like
every other um seven inch android tablet
out there uh starts with uh 16 gigabytes
so uh keep on lookout for this little
thing that's actually pretty cool that
you know we've seen a whole bunch of
these and it's all
i think the nexus 7's fault because
they're the you know that was the one
that sort of made it a viable product
space and now we're just scrambling to
join yeah yeah i mean the kindle fire
came out and everyone bought it but it
was but it wasn't really an airport yeah
yeah and then the nexus 7 came out and
you're like oh we can have a good
android tablet
at a good price and then everyone had to
catch up and fortunately everyone is and
we'll see if this one
this kobo arc
can keep up with everybody else in the
market
so you know if i had one of those i
would probably spend a lot of time
sitting on my porch reading
reading eh tell me more
well the thing is it's very cold right
now because it's winter uh winter has
actually finally just arrived in san
francisco it was a
beautiful balmy 38 degrees this morning
and
these gloves which you may remember from
last year these are etra 5 point gloves
made by british company etre from the
british isles
they have little
fibers woven into the the fingertips
that enable them to be used touch screen
devices
so you can wear the gloves and you can
touch your phone you can send text you
can browse on your tablet without taking
your gloves off there's a lot of people
doing this
but etra sent some to us last year we
really liked them and we gave them away
in the show and we're going to give away
this pair these are
about 60 bucks they're 40 40 british
pounds which is you know roughly 60 usd
and
they're free
to you if you participate in a contest
so what we'd like you to do is take a
photograph with your mobile device
uh of the most archaic
phone
in your home
cell phone right mobile phone uh can it
be a rotary phone um well let's keep it
to mobile phones okay let's keep it to
mobile phones i was gonna leave it
open-ended but you blew it thanks uh
anyway
so take a picture of the most archaic
phone in your home uh you know your old
nokia brick or whatever and tweet it to
at gadget lab so you send that to us
over the holidays so if you have
something in mom and dad's you know
attic that's fine
pick it up take a picture of it send it
to us and after the holidays in early
january we're going to pick a winner
from all the responses the most creative
winner will win the etra
five point gloves from the british isles
it's british it is they're extremely
british they even have like a little bit
of a uh
what is that i don't know that sort of
norwegian pattern anyway the gloves are
awesome we love them and you'll love
them too if you can win them uh we're
taking a break next week but we'll be
back after the holiday and we will
announce the winner of the gloves and
we'll have more things to show you and
more exciting tales from the gadget lab
bye